this is from daily wire uh a
popular Florida realer explained how
hard it has become for today's younger
generation to live a middle class
lifestyle declaring that the old
American dream no longer exists Freddy
Smith and Orlando realer with a popular
Tik Tok account where he posts about the
financial struggles of Millennials in
Generation Z to his 422,000 followers
said young people need a much higher
salary than their parents did to live
the same
lifestyle uh Smith told Fox news this
week a lot lot of us grew up in the
middle class and we watched what middle
class was in the 80s and 90s as
Millennials and nowaday days what has
moved the gold poost more than anything
is the housing market um Smith explained
that younger Americans trying to start
their lives are often priced out of the
housing
market I think most of us in America
would Define the middle class as someone
who can work a 40-hour week career and
can have the income to purchase the
average home in America uh and he says
that you know young people today don't
have that so
you know there's kind of this debate
that goes on and you've got one side
that says that today's gen Z and
Millennials are whiny and weak and
unable to deal with normal challenges
and hardships then you got the other
side that says that well economically
anyway genen Z and Millennials actually
do have it harder than previous
generations especially Baby Boomers well
what's the answer who's right about that
um well it's kind of the worst of all
all worlds because both sides are
basically right
and uh focusing on on the latter for a
moment it's true that today's young
adults are in a significantly worse spot
than their parents were everything you
see
about the things that that younger
people that people my age and if I can
call myself a young adult at this point
but the the things that that people
Millennials and jenz complain about here
it's
true it used to be that you could have a
single inome household on a salary under
$100,000 a year and still own a nice
house with three or four bedrooms two
and a half baths you know a little piece
of property in a safe
neighborhood plus you could have your
two cars you know you have the one car
it takes to work and then a minivan for
you know and that was that was normal
for a lot of people under 40 today that
just just doesn't
exist and so the Baby Boomers had it
very easy in that
respect but I think what we're missing
in the conversation is the
boomers are probably historical
outliers you
know modern industrial society itself is
relatively new in the grand scheme of
things and I I always like anytime we're
talking about things like this I always
like to take you know you try to take a
wider view of the situation first before
you can kind of narrow and focus in and
when you do that you see that that um
well certainly before modern industrial
society and and for thousands of years
before
that if you were not extremely wealthy
then you would have lived what would
seem to us to be an unthinkably
difficult life uh one that for us would
would just be unimaginable drudgery and
hardship you know that's for thousands
of years the the people who were not the
absolute richest of the rich uh
everybody
else like by our standards today lived
just I mean suffering that that that we
can't even imagine according to Forbes
January is the hottest month for hiring
and business owners and hiring managers
are on the hunt for top talent which is
no easy task if you're currently hiring
you can probably relate it's challenging
to find qualif qualified candidates
these days and that's why you need zip
recruiter zip recruiters powerful
matching technology finds the right
people for your roles fast and right now
you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com Walsh immediately after
you post your job zi recruiter smart
technology start showing you candidates
whose skills and experience match it to
ackn um
to to encourage top candidates to
respond to your job post even sooner
Zipperer lets you send them a personal
invite to apply as your rate candidate
Zipperer sends you more of the ones you
like from the thousands of new job
Seekers who join the site this month
find the talent you need to fill all of
your roles with zip recruiter see for
yourself why four out of five employees
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day just go
to this exclusive web address right now
to try Zipperer for free ziar.com Walsh
again that's ziar.com
wsh Zipperer the smartest way to hire
now for them a lot of that was just
everyday
life but for us and the Comforts that
we're used to we we would consider it to
be like torturous suffering and and that
was the case for
Millennia and then um the way that we
all live started to change with the
Industrial Revolution a few gener
Generations into it the Baby Boomers got
to have their single you know family
homes with a half acre of property one
income under six figures and um you know
they they could they could go to the gr
they could do things like go to the
grocery store and buy uh groceries for a
week for the family and and it wouldn't
bankrupt them like they could afford to
buy all the groceries and it was okay
and they had as a generation probably
the easiest life
that any generation of humans have ever
enjoyed in the whole history of human
existence you know the baby boom is like
that's right in that window right there
that was kind of The Sweet Spot and that
is the easiest life it's like that's it
that's for for any generation of humans
they got the easiest uh they they they
got the
best they they pull they pull the best
card um but they didn't really make any
effort to maintain main that for future
Generations in fact they have actively
squandered it and now here we
are you know they I'm speaking
collectively here this doesn't apply to
all them of course but anytime you're
talking you know you're talking about
Generations you're you're you're
speaking
collectively and um so collectively
speaking baby boomers had a very easy
life that was that was passed down to
them um they squandered it and they're
primarily interested in holding on to it
for themselves until they kick the but
um there doesn't appear to be a whole
lot of interest in making sure that you
know future Generations can prosper
financially and
um so what happens to the rest of us
we're kind of headed back down towards
the version of the sort of life that
most humans have lived the fun times in
prosperity didn't last because the
people who enjoyed it didn't care at all
about preserving that experience for
anyone but themselves and uh
and that's how I understand all of this
so that that's where we are I don't this
isn't leading to like a solution I'm
just saying that this this is a
situation that we're in if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there godp speed